and we begin with breaking news here at  six o'clock roads around the area of  twain and royal crest are closed after  police say a driver hit somebody that  happened not too long ago just east of  university center and that's where kate  houston is joining us standing by with  the very latest kate  yes i'm here near palo verde and twain  where several streets are blocked off  here behind me you can see multiple  police units have responded police say  this happened around 4 40 tonight at  least one person is seriously injured  and has been taken to the hospital  police say at one point officers were  doing cpr on scene initially the driver  was reported to have left but police now  say that they do have somebody in  custody now we are waiting on more  details from police and we're going to  bring that to you on air and online so  make sure to stay with us reporting live  near twain and palo verde kate houston  live local now